and i think food is has a very strong
impact in terms of the environmental
footprint
and
everyone is now starting to pay
attention uh to this footprint and i
think it's just a matter of time and we
see it also happening in front of our
eyes right now
it's a matter of time of
eliminating animals in our days
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders meet
leonardo markovic the founder of more
foods
after finishing high school in venezuela
leonardo moved to the usa to study
biomedical engineering a degree he
pursued as it delivered on his ambitions
and cravings for multidisciplinary
fields
this interest in varied topics would
then become evident by his co-founding
of startups in different fields which
include medical devices and management
software for groups of farmers
his underlying driver has always been a
desire to somehow do good then he
founded more foods over two years ago
when he became obsessed with the idea
that we can serve people delicious meats
without the need to use animals me
leonardo
fascinating career besides what you've
been doing the last three years with
more foods and food alternative and meat
alternative
your previous work
i really have to understand
this journey um from
working in medical whether it be device
for to train nurses or with pressure med
and later on agricultural cooperatives
and then being a vendor acquisition
manager of billion vegans transitioning
to food tech it feels like you've been
you know really at the forefront of some
of the most you know revolutionizing
industries today whether it be
specifically medical or with food and
and i i don't usually meet people that
that work at the forefront of these two
how did that happen how did this
transition happen for you and and take
me even back before how you got into
working in med tech
uh sure uh great question so um
i studied biomedical engineering i'm
originally from venezuela from caracas
and uh when i finished high school i
moved to the states and there i studied
biomedical engineering and
that's the first clue as to all the
other things that i did later on that
you you mentioned yourself that it was
it's quite varied and different things
and the reason i study biomedical
engineering is because you have a lot of
different fields within that study so
you have um you have biology chemistry
physics mechanics and many different
fields so i'm quite curious uh quite
curious person
and um
and when i finished uh the university uh
then i i already had a business which we
started to make devices actually to help
train nurses
um that was the first business that i
had and then i had some activities
related to real estate
and then yeah and then i've had many
other activities one of them was a
medical device and a startup in the
medical device arena
it was a device to help to
detect the specific parameter and
intensive care units at this parameter
at the time wasn't it wasn't able to
detect it
continuously and what we did is that we
figured out how to make a machine that
could measure it continuously so it's
similar to like when you know when you
measure the heart rate and or the blood
oxygen concentration in an intensive
care unit that's important to understand
the patient's condition and what we did
is that we um we did a similar device
but for something called intra-abdominal
pressure and then later on uh the
next startup was
you're right it's unrelated it's uh
agriculture so we build software for
agricultural cooperatives
and there what we saw is we saw an
opportunity we saw that there's
and especially for certain crops like if
you're talking about let's say cacao
coffee and different crops
these crops are produced mostly by small
farmers hundreds of thousands of farmers
that work under a net under a
cooperative model so what we did is we
built a
software solution that would allow them
all to connect to this cooperative and
to help manage all their activities
and so what what is it how did
how did that jump happen from working on
intensive care units to
working
in agricultural cooperatives i
understand the technology piece that is
bridging the gap but
but what happened you know for you
personally that made the sleep
um so again
there's the common denominator is also
trying to do
good and so the one of the first things
was so the medical devices and
biomedical engineering um
this is related to going it's doing good
in a very direct manner
and and then like after that journey and
and that startup um i realized that i
was still interested in doing something
that that i thought okay would do
somehow good and and the opportunity to
help and small farmers and to help to
organize their activities
um was something that seemed quite
interesting
um and and this is how we jumped into
this
i well i i love the common denominator
and let's jump to
food tech and where we are
today share with me your personal
relationship to food tech and how you
see food tech as as an entrepreneur for
a second how if you're looking at the
world and you're looking at a vision of
food
where where are we and where do you
think we're going to go to in terms of
food tech
um
i think
that
the world realizes not just in food
that there's
a lot of the products that we produce
the price of the externalities so
basically the costs related to you know
the the resources used and and also the
output let's say the contaminants
produced and the greenhouse emissions
produced are now taken into account
historically in the it's in the price of
products
and i think food is has a very strong
impact in terms of the environmental
footprint
and
everyone is now starting to pay
attention
uh to this footprint and i think it's
just a matter of time and we see it also
happening in front of our eyes right now
um it's a matter of time of
eliminating animals in our days and and
the reason for that one of the reasons
is because of this consciousness of the
externalities and and the outside
factors you know now when you buy a
ticket to fly from
one city to another city
most airlines ask you
um do you wish to pay for to offset your
co2 emissions
um that happens a lot of times when you
buy an airline ticket and and i think
this is just the sign of like you know
seeing that people are more aware and
companies more aware and and and so so
the future is really um
eliminating the use of
more than 15 percent of greenhouse
emissions in the world come from uh
from animal production and um
and and so this is a great way to to
help you know meet our goals in terms of
co2 emissions in the next few years it's
by reducing and eliminating the use of
animals in the food system
sometimes again so we agree
yeah we agree on a brighter world
where we were able to eliminate these 50
of the emissions that are coming as a
result of the supply chain of
manufacturing and distribution of meat
now how do you build a company that is
good and is successful and is making a
positive impact in this domain we have a
lot of companies that are merging this
domain
where what what are the different
interesting places that an entrepreneur
like yourself can come in and make an
impact in this vertical so basically um
noticing that most of the company that
there is this opportunity um to change
our
food distribution and our food items the
products that we eat in order to meet
some of the goals of the environment in
the world
look people food is something very
emotional it's something that we're used
to eating a lot of us eat animal
products because
we
you know
because we we we grew up with that and
it's habits and and there are certain
characteristics and qualities to the
products that we that are marvelous and
i think now with technology and the
understanding that we have in food and
and you know food technology there's a
great opportunity um to look at those
items that we really like to look at the
qualities of those items for example of
a piece of
beef or chicken etc to understand what
are some of the qualities or for example
the juiciness or the tenderness
the chewiness to it to look at those
qualities that we love
and instead of using those animal
ingredients and products to use
plant-based ingredients in order to
create those products i think right now
we're at a very interesting
place because of the knowledge that we
have on on how to use those plant-based
ingredients and there's many uh
plant-based ingredients that are to be
explored and haven't been explored and
that's what
by the way is is really
i'm really passionate about is like most
of the products in the market are
are using for the plant for the meat
alternative market are using three main
ingredients and that's a soy protein p
protein and seitan on the soy protein
and the sedan are major allergens and
they have a somewhat negative perception
i i don't believe that the perception is
correct but a lot of people uh believe
this and the p protein has a somewhat
strong all flavor which means it needs
to be quite processed
and and so i think those ingredients are
are great and i don't have anything
against that but i think there's so many
ingredients in the world
that can be explored
um so for example the some of the
ingredients that we explore are the side
streams from the edible oil industry
so what we do at more foods is we we
saw all these ingredients that are we
call them castaway ingredients so things
that other companies
in the food industry are not using and
we see a great opportunity to use those
in order to create these meat
alternative products that maybe i don't
know if you have a chance to look at our
in our website or we have pictures in
other places so it's kind of um
funny or interesting to
to
to understand
that we so i'll explain a little bit
about the process so you have these um
side streams so you have for example
sunflower oil right so there's about 32
million tons of sunflower oil that are
produced every year and what happens is
you take the seed you companies and
those industrial companies press the
seed the oil comes out of the seed and
then you have this leftover cast away
material and what we do at more foods is
we figure out how to use these
leftover ingredients or if i would
rephrase it i would say these castaway
ingredients
in order to take them from
the um from the extra product from these
industries to creating final products
right
if we're looking for a second to
understand
why there's a discrepancy of of products
that are being used because i think it's
an important piece of the conversation
here because you're you're outlining a
thesis saying there's all these
different ingredients that we can
leverage
that that will make their own that'll
make for for
you know is
better meals more sustainable
great business why is it that the three
ingredients that you mentioned before
are they at the forefront are they the
cheapest are they the most easy to to to
to get are they the most known why did
we converge on these the three main
ingredients that you were talking about
sure so like um some of it makes some
logical sense and i'll i'll go into it
and and some of it is just historical
you know some things just happen like
historically and then like
the whole industry is based on that
so
so for example so so soy um soil is like
the most prevalent okay soy is an
amazing crop it's it's really high in
protein it has a balanced amino acid and
and that's also one of the reasons why
it's used extensively in the uh in the
cattle industry and the
and the animal food and you know it's
used for animal feed
um and it's rather cheap to produce and
by the way it
that that's a crop that also oil is
extracted from it so there's soy oil
and um
and so
because the
animal feed industry is such a large
industry it's you know multiple times
bigger than that the the food industry
for for humans like the quantities the
volumes of food so that that was a
natural direction to go into just to try
to figure out how you could maybe modify
or or what could you do with these side
streams from the soya oil and also from
from the cattle industry in order to
create foods for products so this is for
soy and then for seitan um it's um it
has roots it's um it's it comes
initially from from asia and uh but
satan i don't know if most people are
aware of this it's basically the protein
component of wheat
so again wheat is like one of the
largest crops in the world so
because it's such a large crop it's
relatively inexpensive and it's also
quite available and it also produces a
pretty nice texture uh the wheat so
those are the soy and the and the
and and the seitan and then you have the
p protein the p protein is uh is
relatively new in the game
so here's again and by the way the pea
protein is interesting because initially
it kind of came from a similar story of
a side stream or castaway ingredient
so in um in in asia
the carbohydrates so they they take the
peas and they extract the protein to
have the carbohydrates and then they
make things like pastas and noodles okay
from this so then they started to have
the protein side streams okay
and they started to explore with it and
now a lot of industries are are
exploring it
but it's so interesting because so in in
so so for example in in asia the
protein is a side stream okay and in
in the west right now because of the
meat alternative industries for example
beyond meat uses some um
pea protein
there's many companies that are setting
up and have set up to extract the
protein and the uh the kind of the
carbohydrates are
uh a side stream so it's quite
interesting the side stream thing even
though we live in you know the year 2022
there's still informational gaps and and
you have these differences in what can
be used in which way
besides the technology and the
innovativeness of what you're talking
about
then there's the consumer side right
you're creating a product that consumers
need to love and need to
want to to purchase so tell me a little
bit about more foods as a company and
sort of what your strategy is in terms
of the actual product that you're
creating and and then who the customer
is and how you're getting to that
customer
yeah sure so
in um in in most of the world especially
for if we look at for example to give
you a number in the western world
there's um the numbers are normally
above 30 percent of the population that
fit into this category that we call
fluxitarians
which is basically what it means is more
than 30 percent of the population is
looking to reduce their meat consumption
for different reasons whether they have
concerns about the environment or about
animal welfare or about their health
there's different reasons for that and
um
so this is our target audience at this
stage of the company
and these they're looking for things
that are clean label clean label means
that there's nothing on the label that
you know that sounds strange to them
and it they're also looking for short
lists of ingredients because again when
people see a very long list of
ingredients they sometimes assume that
it's highly processed
um
and for ingredients that they recognize
and sound familiar to them and so we we
hit the
the nail in the head with with all these
uh with all these concerns that people
may have
so we make a product which is clean
label has short list of ingredients and
we use ingredients that in fact are even
considered superfoods you know the the
two major protein sources on our in our
food product are the first one is
pumpkin uh seed flour and the second one
is a sunflower seed flour
so um yeah amazing and in terms of the
the go to market and the actual products
that you're creating what is that
process like
sure um in terms of um
you mean the process well i'll explain
okay so the the
the pipeline now that we have is we have
a product which is more like a beef type
of product okay in terms of the texture
and the appearance
and with this uh product we already can
scale we can produce in a large scale
and and we already started the sales
here in israel in tel aviv we have
multiple chains of restaurants that
started using our products
and
so because we produce these this meat we
can cut it into different form factors
so right now we have something which is
more like a pulled meat
and then we also have
my nude steak and we have also these
chunks more foods chunks and we're
working on different types of cuts
this is like unique know-how in itself
um
so this is one form of like how we're
expanding into the future but there's
many things like there's many things
that can be done so for example you have
the form factors and then if you just
zoom in into one specific form factor
you can flavor it in different ways so
you know let's say we go with the chunks
the chunks can be like indian curry or
they can be for example a mexican dish
or you know a variety of different
cuisines so we really can develop a lot
of products uh from
from um
from from these from this uh from a
specific cut
and then looking into the future we make
other products like more similar to a
pork meat and then land meat and then
various others
now in terms of there you know there's
there's obviously different strategies
that you can also go there's the direct
to consumer there's the more the b2b
side with the restaurants that you're
talking about as you're mapping out all
these different options and i'm sure
that this is a an ongoing thinking
process
what is you know why why did you choose
to go through more of the restaurants
versus more than direct to consumer
routes
sure the
food service food service means like
restaurants catering um
coffee shops et cetera the reason that
we went in this direction
is only a momentary decision what i mean
is this is the go to market strategy
it's the initial way to launch the
products into our market and that's
because we can
it's quicker to start entering the
market the marketing
expenses are lower
and and we can see how the restaurants
are using our products and it's a
two-way street you know we learn from
them and uh and they learn from us how
the product can can be cooked in in
various cuisines and and this gives us
knowledge and information on eventually
when we're going to reach the retail
segment we'll know what type of flavors
you know people really like and what
type of cuts they really like and many
other details
so so essentially leveraging the the
ability of the restaurant to sort of
distributors and feedback mechanisms to
get a quick feedback loop to be able to
improve on the product and then once you
are ready to continue with other
verticals your you have enough of the
feedback to understand okay this this is
actually a product we've reached part of
market fit so you're not just looking
for a product market fit with the
selling to the restaurants you're also
looking for them to help you reach a
product market fit to the end consumers
which obviously are at the end the
people who are consuming this and and a
just a really interesting you know
journey all around and food tech and and
me tech and and
alternatives and and i love the way that
you're looking at
at the different
ways of creating the the alternative
sources of of meat and protein that are
non-traditional and finding the
differentiation at the end looking
towards the north northern star of of a
world that we all agree we should be at
and now it's a question of who are the
players that are going to be enablers
for that and it sounds like more foods
is positioned to to have a significant
part in it and
leonardo i really want to thank you for
spending this time with me i really
appreciate it and thank you very much
thank you michael
you